every generation has their era defining
writer Victorian era had Charles Dickens
the 80s had Stephen King in the 2020s
Colleen
Hoover okay so a little while ago I
reviewed a book called it ends with us
all my thoughts on that still stand I
would be willing to read another Colleen
Hoover book go watch the video I think
it's a it's a good video but of course
after a massive sensation there has to
be a sequel all right but here's the
thing I was planning to not like this
book it has very simple writing style
characters are mostly flat and
one-dimensional there's some problematic
depictions and interpretations of
abusive behavior and yet I thought the
first book had a really strong message
about domestic abuse and domestic
violence the book overall is not as
interesting as it ends with us it's
basically like an extended Apple she
even says you know in the intro like hey
this is for my fans who wanted to see
more of these characters yeah so I like
the book
we're getting into it I tried to give it
starts with us a fair Shake went out for
a walk into a coffee shop nearby luckily
I got there and back without getting wet
we moved around near Seattle lately so
it's been raining a lot I honestly have
my vessies to thank for that have you
heard of Bessie I absolutely love having
vests you know I've been using the uh my
older pair everywhere but I've been
loving their new model the storm burst
these are perfect for long walks and
Hikes I've been taking lately I never
have to decide what shoes to wear in the
winter anymore I just leave these by the
front door because they're 100
waterproof this is sponsored by the way
great for the unpredictable Spring
weather they'll they'll keep your feet
dry I mean let me tell you they're
comfortable and stylish sneakers you can
wear every day made from dime attacks
which is a dual climate material that
keeps you cool in summer and warm and
Colder Weather it doesn't feel like it
should be waterproof it doesn't look
like it should be waterproof but it is
they're super comfortable they're
durable and breathable I mean I have two
pairs of vessels now and I I wear them
literally everywhere Rubber Sole to it
it's like super grippy there's a ton of
ice the other day and Nadia kept
slipping but I had my vessels on and I
was like huh I'm I'm I'm not gonna slip
she fell a bunch I didn't help her up
but if you like to keep your feet warm
and not think too much about the kind of
shoe you wear every day these are the
shoes for you bestie has a bunch of
different styles to choose from for any
activity look I'm a simple man I don't
like to think too hard about the kind of
shoes I'm gonna be wearing every day now
that I have the besties it's like check
out the messy storm burst and other
styles at fessie.com man carrying thing
get the bestie sneaker you want and use
this code for 15 off your entire order
thank you to vesi for sponsoring this
video again all right
back to the video Colleen you Menace
there's gonna be more of a spoiler talk
at the end of the video so you can see
me ranting for the most part I just want
to talk about why I think this book is
better than people give it credit for
and also still what is wrong with it you
know what does Colin Hooper say about
our time what is her success and what is
the backlash to her success say because
I think that's actually a more
interesting conversation to be had I
learned that Colin Hoover Uh was a
social worker and I mean you can tell
that she she's familiar and able to
really discuss in detail kind of how
abuse Works in cycles of abuse Not Just
Between You Know A Partners but between
parents parents and kids I run my finger
over the tattoo on my shoulder feeling
the small scars he left with his teeth
bral did these to me at the highest
points of our relationship what would he
be capable of at the lowest like this is
a very honest thing do you know to put
into a book and I really appreciate that
yet on the flip side you know you have
things that get pass over that field
unnecessary or just like not specific
enough you know I think that avoiding
specificity can lead you to stuff like
this I like seeing what he's wearing and
where he's at and the basis he makes
when he says the things he says but
here's the problem right we don't really
need this book it's largely unnecessary
it just kind of becomes an exercise in
exploring the themes of abuse in a
different way which I'm actually fine
with I mean people who are complaining
like oh this book didn't need to be
written well it was like people wanted
it it's selling a billion copies so what
are you gonna it's just that's just how
it we're exploring the relationship
between two of the characters in the
first book it felt a little bit more up
in the air I mean you know I think the
first one inevitable this one was kind
of like where is it even gonna end how
much of their relationship are we going
to see you know how messy is this going
to get the abusive character from the
first book is in the second book and
he's still the way he is I really was
afraid that there was going to be some
romanticizing of his behavior and it was
a very realistic depiction of this type
of person and I liked where Colleen
Hoover was taking well complicate your
life or ryle's life his complications
become my complications he's the father
of my child like I haven't read a lot of
books where you're dealing with the
complications of having like someone in
your life who you don't want to have in
your life but it's you know divorce it's
messy problems remain however I feel
like Colleen Hoover is afraid to make
things messy you know I feel like
everything has to be neat and concise
and come together and have a point if
she were willing to bring in some chaos
maybe and into the her worlds I think
they'd be more relatable in a way we
have characters who are kind of like um
Victorian Heroes wonderful good
protagonists and we have the wonderful
good love interest and then we have the
evil villain you know who's trying to
ruin it one character it's Atlas Atlas
is the character I'm talking about it is
like this perfect person who just feels
so Bland and this gets me to my next
point so this book is written from two
perspectives now we have Lily and her
you know long time love interest from
when she was a kid and you know the
great disrupter in the first book
Lillian Atlas and it's their love story
oh this is random but Atlas FaceTiming
her out of the blue
when he said he was going to call
that's sick Behavior that's not okay and
when we're in Lily's perspective we see
everything when we're Atlas perspective
we're seeing everything you know it's
written in the first person present
tense which I think is a big part of the
appeal of the book Lily has an
interesting internal monologue you know
I think that knows where her limits are
in terms of trying to break out of this
abusive relationship with her now
ex-husband to navigate that you know how
much sympathy does she show how does she
you know deal with the guilt you know I
think that her process is very realist
has some of that however there becomes a
point in the book when he is like the
the spokesperson for the author kind of
speaks on behalf of Colleen Hoover at a
certain point and I get that there is an
element of fantasy to romance it seems
like people are don't even like Atlas I
mean they like Atlas like admire him as
a person before being a good person but
he's not super lovable I guess in a way
he was homeless he has an abusive mother
and obsessed with Lily and and making
her life perfect and he's just a great
guy he owns two restaurants I mean this
guy hi he's been through [__] he was
abused he was in the military and
there's no clear indication that he got
over things or has processed things you
know he's become successful in business
but maybe calling Hoover's vision of the
world like that's that's that's a sign
that you're fine there's no politics in
these books there's nothing to say about
world events but when we do get a
glimpse into these characters lives you
get maybe a sense that Colleen Hoover is
a touch removed these days I don't know
I think I'm tired of it or tired in
general it's a lot and it's tedious work
for not very much Financial return
Lily's talking about you know owning a
successful flower shop her romantic
interest loans to successful businesses
and her ex-husband is a wildly
successful neurosurgeon I mean I'm proud
that it's been successful and that I did
it but sometimes I daydream about
working in a factory assembly line
stop it I the whole time reading this I
couldn't get over how well written this
book is
hear me you may be saying what no this
is romance trash this is just like
written at like a fourth grade reading
level people who have never read you
know in years are picking these up and
saying it's you know great yeah
you know how hard that is to do I don't
know if it's like the late hours I'm
doing this right now in the caffeine but
I don't think people are quite
appreciating how hard it is to write
with such an invisible simple readable
stuff that takes year that take that's
so hard to do you know every scene like
there are the clunky lines and the
things that are jarring that pull you
out but these books are well plotted
they have beats that hit that are
consistent that keep you reading they
are page Turners having a lack of detail
allowing the audience to just fall in
with a you know simple premise like yeah
that it's not great that the characters
can be Bland and are forgettable but it
literally gets you to read the book like
it is insanely readable I was looking at
like Colleen Hoover interviews and
discussions and she talked about how you
know when she writes she she overwrites
and that final product is usually like a
third of what she actually wrote and you
can tell you may argue about the
artistic value I think that it is there
is Artistic value I think it's also just
skill value like this is incredibly
skillful right I think people should get
off their High horses just a little bit
I think the issue is that it ends with
us it had that twist where like you're
reading a romance but no it's actually a
story about abuse you know I think that
is a trick I think it was an effective
trick but a lot of people didn't like
that and I think that's that's fine and
I think that doing that trick you're
going to have like a messy situation
this book is way more clear-cut here's
the romance and then there's the abuse
stuff the romance is more pure there I
don't read romance you know but I can
get into a book like this you know
there's romance books that I've tried to
read but that I can't get into but this
it's so effortless it's like um you know
people who look at abstract art and are
like well I could do that no anyways I
don't really know what else to say about
this book except it confounds me and
frustrates me with how I appreciate it
but also dislike it and if you'd like to
hear me rant a little bit because I have
some things to get off my chest stick
around if not then go bye bye again
while this book is definitely like
totally unnecessary like it was nice to
have Atlas and Lily just kind of like
the idea of okay they could be together
but I honestly think that she handled
the story pretty well you know the B
plot was good with atlas's brother and
him dealing with his mom like I thought
all of that was really interesting that
was the most interesting stuff about
Atlas for sure because he's Bland Lily
dealing with motherhood and dating it
was a nice access to that kind of being
an early mom and that kind of like
experience and getting to see what that
was like her and how she managed dating
and also dealing with this uh abusive
ass
um ex-hus honestly some of the lines
that he says like just the kind of
narcissism the kind of gaslighting just
gave me chills I think that Colleen
Hoover has a really solid grasp over on
people like that on the down side Atlas
and Lily's relationship I thought just
lost all steam after they come together
once they're together once they decide
like oh we're not taking this slow
anymore they're like we're getting
married even though they don't say that
like the last 30 pages I thought were
incredibly slow I thought all tension
was lost biggest issue with was with
like the the third Act was like the
culminating scene so all right here's
what should have happened I think
because like Atlas and Lily's
relationship just was too perfect we
need to give Atlas some flaws what if
he's like not super open and like that's
an issue where like he can't be open to
Lily and that overcorrects with a rile
you know what if when Ryle comes and
punches him in the face he doesn't give
him like a Mr Rogers talk and and just
spout the words of the author that
annoyed the hell out of me Ryle comes
and we're like oh my God ryle's such an
[__] he comes and punches him at his
own restaurant Atlas is so perfect it's
just it annoyed the hell out of me like
can we just let him be slightly
realistic he sits calm and talks to him
like he's a child giving him some wisdom
we want conflict we want something to
happen we want there to be danger and
then it just seems like it Fizzles I
think Colleen Hoover just really wanted
to leave things as they are with this
Dynamic of like they have to deal with
rile like there's some changes in her
relationship to Ryle and how interact
which I thought was good I liked when
Alyssa and Marshall finally talk to him
and like have their intervention like
that was a good scene it just felt like
there's so much lost potential there the
book just um it worked it was fine it
was fine I think it did the best with
what it could there were some memorable
scenes the sex scenes I just didn't care
about like they they really weren't that
interested one of them was so boring
because like all the tension was left
out of it they were just like having sex
and I was like all right Atlas just at a
certain point like become so boring and
all that's interesting about him is his
brother and his mom I just I don't think
Colleen could get into his head and and
experience what he's experiencing in
that way and it's too bad you know
because I think there was really good
potential anyways that's what I have to
say about the sequel to as with us it
starts with us anyways I'm tired thank
you to Bessie for sponsoring this video
bye bye